So we've got some major breaking news on the
show up.
Producer Pat Ford
is sadly no longer producer for the David
Pakman show, but he's not gone.
He is now moving on to a new shiny position
being supervising producer for the David Pakman
show.
Pat's been here for a couple of years.
He's not leaving.
He got a promotion.
We're going to be ramping up a whole bunch
of new initiatives on the show.
The one sad thing for some people, uh, about
all this is that you're not going to be hearing
from pat and nearly as much on the broadcast
show, which includes podcasts, radio, TV,
and sort of like our normal youtube clips.
But Pat is going to be on the daily bonus
show.
So anyone, one who wants to continue to hear
and see pat dailies still can and as his new
initiatives get underway, we're actually going
to be hearing more about that from pat on
the bonus show, including what he's working
on, things coming up on the show and a lot
more.
So it's a sort of bittersweet announcement.
It's basically a result of pat just has a
ton of stuff to do and a lot more now that
he is going to be supervising the production
of the show.
And uh, this has been, you know, going back
to the producer Louis days, this has been
a thing within the producer role for a long
time.
You might remember if you've been with us
this long, when Louis started on the show,
his producer years ago, the idea was that
he'd, uh, not be participating in the show
because of how, uh, the studio was set up
and a bunch of different things.
But at the time, because Louis, his role was
much smaller because remember the show was
like once every other week Louis started kind
of chiming in and some people liked it, some
people didn't like it.
And since then it's been very kind of like
off again on again.
We're sometimes we'd hear from Louis sometimes
not depending on what was going on with the
show that day or week, same with pat, but
there is so much new stuff going on now, um,
that it's just much more time efficient for
pat to be working on other aspects of the
show while the show is being produced rather
than monitoring the show's production minute
to minute.
So we're going to be getting a lot more done
and that's the path forward.
And I'll tell you about some of the exciting
things that are being added effective immediately
and or rolled out in the next few weeks.
Number one by significant very popular demand,
we are ramping up subtitles captions and transcripts
for the program.
A ton of people who have asked about this,
some people it's because they're hard of hearing
other people just really like being able to
kind of read along with what we're saying.
Others want to be able to read what's on the
show rather than actually watching the clips.
So we're going to be immediately implementing
youtube captions and subtitles.
And then over the short to medium term, we
are also going to be generating daily transcripts
of the show, which you can, uh, read, you
can read on your computer, you'll be able
to read on your mobile phone if you prefer
to sort of like read the show rather than
listen to it when you're commuting or whatever
else.
So that is one thing which is one of the most
common requests and it's actually quite a
bit of work.
Um, surprisingly or not for people who know
what goes into that.
And Pat is going to be spearheading that.
And then also, this is really great news.
We're going to be expanding our Facebook video
presence to put the entire shows clips on
Facebook.
And you might be saying, well what are you
talking about David?
I see your stuff on Facebook already.
Here's how it Kinda how that has evolved over
time.
Years ago we would take a youtube clip and
we would embed it on Facebook.
Um, a couple of years ago, Facebook started
allowing what we would call native video uploads
to Facebook, which means we're no longer embedding
a youtube clip, but we're directly uploading
the video to Facebook and you see it in Facebook's
video player.
And we did that a little bit with like 30
or 40% of the show.
And then nine months ago Facebook launched
video monetization on Facebook.
So that was an immediate incentive to increase
how much of the show we were uploading to
Facebook and we upped it to like two thirds
of the daily show, but it was making like
no money.
Even though it was quote monetized, it was
making I think like 30 bucks a month for the
entire month of, you know, most of the last
nine months.
But in the last couple of months, Facebook,
video revenue has started to go up and because
we're always looking for alternatives to youtube
monetization, this is potentially a really
good revenue source for us that can keep sort
of the risk of any one platform failing us
lower by spreading out where we are uploading
video.
So starting effective immediately.
We're kind of going to be taking the plunge
and we'll be putting all of the daily show
clips on both youtube and Facebook and that's
another project pat is going to be overseeing.
We're looking at posting classic viral clips,
which were on youtube, but we're never on
Facebook to the Facebook page to expose some
of the newer audience to them.
People who haven't seen some of the old classic
viral stuff.
And then lastly, we're making a technical
upgrade to the show effective today, which
is going to pretty significantly improve both
the video and audio quality of the show on
everything but the smallest screen.
So if you watch the show on your phone, on
your mobile phone, um, you're probably not
going to notice much of a difference.
But if you're watching on computer monitors
like 20 inches or larger or watching on TV
watching, uh, in high definition, you are
immediately going to see a pretty significant
visual improvement rolled out over the next
couple of days.
So exciting stuff, thanks to everybody's support.
More exciting announcements or upcoming sign
up for memberships.
Of course, that's the best way to support
us.
There's lots of ways to support us now.
Youtube memberships and Facebook subscriptions
or all of that stuff.
The best two options, our patrion where we
get 95% of your contribution.
Um, and then website memberships where we
get about 97% of your contribution, everything
minus a 2.9% payment processing fee.
So those remain the best ways to support the
show.
Uh, more stuff upcoming very soon and an exciting
announcements.
I can't wait to tell you about